der ausbruch des corona virus auf einem
expeditionsschiff ohne
intensivversorgung eingeschlossen in der
eisigen arktis das klingt nach einem
absoluten albtraum der konnte anfang
april nur knapp verhindert werden denn
ein expeditionsteilnehmer der zum
messflügen für die mosaik expedition
aufbrechen sollte wurde positiv auf saas
kopf 2 getestet und jetzt muss die ganze
expedition komplett umgeplant werden
klicks und fitschen die gibt's täglich
spannende science sidos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke wo dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen clixoom gibt es jetzt mit den
wissenschafts news auch täglich als
audio podcast die links zum podcast bei
spotify und apple sind unten in der
video beschreibung die mosaik expedition
ist die größte arktis-expedition die sie
gegeben hat der deutschen
forschungseisbrecher polarstern hat gut
100 forschende an bord und driftet durch
die zentralarktis eingefroren im boller
als wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen aus 20 nationen
untersuchen auf der expedition die
arktis im jahresverlauf im herbst 2009
10 ist die expedition gestartete hat
bereits erfolgreich zwei schichtwechsel
der crew absolviert in bremerhaven und
den anderen forschungseinrichtungen die
an der expedition beteiligt sind
bereiten sich schon die teilnehmen des
nächsten trifft abschnitts auf ihren
einsatz vor
doch da gibt es einen riesen haken
jetzt sind darunter auch teams die
begleitende messflügen durch die
zentralarktis durchführen sollen doch es
gibt jetzt schlechte nachrichten für die
expedition ein wissenschaftler der an
bord gehen sollte wurde positiv auf
kronaveter skoff 2 getestet als er sich
in bremerhaven mit seinem team auf hielt
das von dort aus nach spitzbergen reisen
sollte da war seine infektion schon
wieder am abklingen und er zeigte keine
symptome
auch die kontaktpersonen wurden getestet
waren aber negativ das rund 20 köpfige
team sollte anfang april nach
spitzbergen aufbrechen um von dort aus
mit zwei forschungs flugzeugen messflüge
über die zentrale aktes durchzuführen
und in ein paar wochen sollten die
flugzeuge bei der polarstern
zwischenlanden alle teilnehmenden wurden
wegen des corona virus falls für zwei
wochen in quarantäne gesteckt die
pandemie wirkt sich auch auf die
künftigen expeditionsteams aus erst war
geplant alle teams die für die mutter
mosaik expedition in die arktis gehen
sollten vor dem abflug auf das virus
testen denn wenn das virus es
tatsächlich auf das isolierte
forschungsschiff polarstern schaffen
sollte wäre das verheerend für die crew
dort gibt es kaum möglichkeiten schwer
erkrankte crewmitglieder zu versorgen
und die infektion würde sich an bord
sehr schnell ausbreiten so wie es sich
auf kreuzfahrtschiffen schon zugetragen
hat für die forschungsgruppe der arktis
expedition stellt die ausbreitung des
virus deshalb eine besonders schlimme
bedrohung da doch bisher ist der
forschungsleiter markus rex vom
alfred-wegener-institut noch
zuversichtlich die crew durch die
strengen sicherheitsmaßnahmen schützen
zu können aber er räumt auch ein dass
das risiko nicht gleich null ist dabei
gilt maximale vorsicht und die hat jetzt
zu absolut krassen maßnahmen geführt die
gesundheit und sicherheit aller
expeditionsteilnehmer hat absolut ja
höchste priorität und deswegen wird die
aktuelle besetzung jetzt auch zwei
monate länger auf der polarstern bleiben
sie wird nicht mehr ausgetauscht damit
auf keinen fall irgendjemand auf das
schiff kommen kann der infiziert ist
denn eigentlich war im april der nächste
schichtwechsel geplant per flugzeug
sollte er von spitzbergen aus erfolgen
die norwegische inselgruppe ist aber
wegen der korona pandemie gesperrt dort
können jetzt flugzeuge weder starten
noch landen jetzt bleibt die aktuelle
crew also zwei monate länger auf der
polarstern im mai soll die polarstern
sich dann aus eigener kraft aus dem eis
befreien also die expedition
außerplanmäßig unterbrechen und trifft
sich dann mit zwei versorgungsschiffen
vor spitzbergen und dann werden die
sicherheitsmaßnahmen absolut streng sein
die teilnehmenden werden zweimal
getestet und zwar bei der abreise und
bei der ankunft so dass eben möglichst
verhindert wird dass irgendjemand der
infiziert wird auf das schiff gerät die
crew wird also im mai dann ausgetauscht
und neue vorräte geladen und dann geht
es zurück um die mission fortzusetzen
auf dem schiff gibt es auch noch eine
isolierstation das so wenn also jemand
durchschlüpfen sollte dass er dann
isoliert oder sie isoliert werden kann
klimawandel gefährliche expedition zum
nordpol polarstern bricht alle rekorde
ja sehr spannende mission ist das hier
gibt es also mehr infos an
anschauen und klicks zum nature
abonnieren sehr sehr cooler kanal mit
ohne ende videos über umwelt und natur
und teil der bildungsinitiative vom 3ds
for future wir bilden zukunft also
unbedingt anklicken anschauen und bitte
bitte bitte abonnieren es lohnt sich für
jeden der sich für diese themen
interessiert bis dann bleibt dran